all right we're gonna mix it up this
week and talk about something a little
less controversial than usual feminism
everyone agrees on that right okay good
that's what I thought my guest this week
is christina hoff sommers
christina is a former philosophy
professor author and a speaker for the
American Enterprise Institute known for
her critique of late 20th century
feminism over the past few months I've
become familiar with Christina because
her name kept popping up all over my
Twitter feed at first related to
gamergate and now because of her
tongue-in-cheek commentary on campus
free speech trigger warnings and safe
spaces actually thanks to Twitter and to
all of you who've helped connect me with
like-minded people the show has really
taken off in a way I couldn't have
imagined suddenly I find myself immersed
with people I truly admire and respect
we're all talking to each other in
various mediums and strengthening the
ideals we stand for even if we don't
agree on every specific issue one such
issue that I haven't tackled too deeply
yet is feminism and that's exactly why I
wanted to have Christina on as an equity
feminist Christina cares about both
women's and men's rights you know that
whole two things can be true at once the
idea that I've been talking about I
should say that feminism in and of
itself isn't one of my bread-and-butter
topics as you guys know I love
discussing politics foreign policy
religion secularism and more but haven't
done a ton on the topic of feminism of
course the argument could be made that
feminism and the fight for women's
rights is an absolute through line
through all of the topics I just
mentioned generally speaking where women
are treated with equality we see fairer
societies with more secular values and
less radicalism this isn't a coincidence
nor is it something that should be
overlooked actually if anything it
should be embraced if a society treats
their women fairly it is almost always a
more successful Society on every other
front the battle for equality of women
has been different all over the world
and continues in almost every form today
this is one of the main issues that I
want to discuss with Christina how is
the battle for equality evolved over the
years
have there been unintended consequences
by coming so far in the battle has
feminism morphed into something that
feminists of the 1960s wouldn't even
wreck
today and what happens when an equality
movement actually accomplishes its goals
do we move on to what's next there's the
battle never truly end as you can see
I've got a lot of questions and I hope
christina has some of the answers for me
the battle for women's rights is the
same battle that has been fought by the
other for all time I want women to have
a hundred percent of the opportunity
that men have I want the doors to be
open and the glass ceiling to be
shattered winning these battles doesn't
mean it has to come at the expense of
men nor does it mean that men should
suddenly become less than women and at
the same time we should acknowledge the
sexes are actually different and that's
okay too
from our hunter-gatherer days to today
gender roles have existed long before
any of us pretending there aren't some
differences in the sexes won't magically
make it true
perhaps we can try to embrace these
differences rather than tacking labels
on everyone and thinking that one
group's equality can only come at the
expense of another groups opportunity if
men are from Mars and women are from
Venus then perhaps it's time we brought
both sexes back to earth